I have to make a
confession against my best friend's
advice I agree to write and to produce a
moo you know one of those massive up
online courses that University
administrators believe to be the
solution to contemporary education and
not just any but one on the topic I have
labeled scientific
Humanities that after having watched
Frederick wisman new documentary called
campus about the day-to-day life in the
offices and classrooms of the University
of California at berley I realized that
I had chosen a strange label since it
appears according to this film that
science is just as under attack as the
humanity is and not under
my you an attack from social
constructivist who would deny the
robustness of its conclusion but from
administrators financers and politicians
in some from the perspectives of what is
generally called evaluation that is a
new mood throughout the developed world
that no longer thinks about anything
important but simply count numbers of
papers published and quantity of money
stacked up before closing down
departments
that long-term basic science could be
threatened in the way that has already
been done for the learning of ancient
Greek the Deering of Mesopotamian clay
tablets or the interpretation of
Whitehead's metaphysics maybe a radical
way to solve a famous much too famous
two cultures divide little would have
thought probable 40 years ago when I
started in science studies when the
field started that our task would not
only be to breach the two cultures
divide but also to defend the two
cultures together that of science as
well as that of the humanities against a
slow and it seems irresistible form of
obscurantism I'm sure you have heard of
a vast movement starting in Italy for
replacing fast food by slow food but you
might not be aware that Isabella stener
a philosopher one of the best example of
the two cult scholar had to issue a plea
for slow
science and other science is possible
manifest for a slow down of a Sciences
is this not an excellent definition of
humanties an attempt at slowing down the
science and bringing back bringing them
back to
Earth by opening a third front against
scholarship broadly conceived what could
be called the accounting auditing and
evaluating craze I don't call it for
abuse reason in the culture opens new
opportunity for all those Scholars
whatever the fields but such a set of
practices tend to
suffocate my point is that it might be
easier to Res resist such a deadly Trend
now that both science and the humanities
are on the same side at least those are
the opportunities but I will try to
stress with you in two successive
lectures it is under the notion of
agency that I've have regrouped some of
the Insight I gain from my work in
science studies and the title how better
to register the agency of things tonight
agency one will de more with simotics
that is with the trajectories of
meanings tomorrow night agency 2 will
deal de with a more difficult aspect
namely with onology that is the science
of what is the crossing almost another
word called autonomy The Crossing
between what is and what should be the
drawing of the rules of what is which is
important for
Gia I will try to speak as if it was
possible to devise a common
language for those who thought
themselves to be in two different and
mostly opposite camps
until they have been submitted to the
same attacks by a third party bent on
closing down all centers of
learning it's ver an exercise in
diplomacy can we AE together so as to
resist a new
enemy but to make sure that you don't
put too much false hope in what I'm
going to say let me warn you at the
beginning with the quote from
Whitehead the critical School confines
itself to verbal analyis within the
limits of the
dictionary the speculative school that
of Whitehead appeals to direct insight
and Endeavors to indicate its meaning by
further appeal to situation which
promote such specific Insight it then
enlarge the dictionary the Divergence
between the school is the quarrel
between safety and adventure and
actually coming from Montreal and the
custom officer to to whom I told that I
was giving a lecture at Yale asked me
and I was a bit taken aback what is
there to say that they don't know
already and I have to confess that I was
absolutely unable to
answer so this is why speculative that's
the word
speculative if there is something common
to science and the humanity it is the
habit of moving back and forth between
actant to actors as my generous
introduct already told you actant is
part of stic jargon and I agree that the
word could put off those train in the
Natural Sciences but as a practice it's
fairly common movement all entities
manipulated by scientist start as a list
of action and then slowly coales later
into the name of an object that
summarizes or stabilizes them for
further
retrieval even though this is how
Discovery is achieved every day this is
such a trivial transformation that it
disappears from view as soon as it's
achieved for instance episode one a pad
of cotton absorbed water first then
episode two it's name
hydrophilic the difference between the
two episodes apart from the use of gble
Greek etimology is that absorbing water
is an action performed on some lab bench
with some material
Contraption by some people who don't yet
know what the properties of the material
under scrutiny are while hydrophilic
cotton is a well-known substance that
has as one of its attribute the property
of absorbing water to use again the
language of semiotics the first is a
performance you cannot deduce what it is
from what you slowly register it is
actually doing while the second is a
competence from what it is you may draw
the conclusion that it will be able in
the future to do this and that and of
course the difference between the
substance and the attributes can be
couched as a philosophical
ideom but it's important at this stage
to take the difference as a temporal
marker and a fully practical distinction
what was at time t a name of action a
list of competences an experiment made
by people ignoring what they were
dealing with becomes later at time t +
one the name of a substance endowed with
attributes although the concept of
substance can be asked to play a role of
what lies under the
properties it may also mean in a more
mundane Manner and depending on how you
play with the etimology of the word
substance what subsist instead of
substance subsist subsistance instead of
substance after stabilization throughout
the PA falia of the thought Collective
as lud fck one of the founder of science
studies said the concept of Discovery
before being transformed into a
philosophical conundrum should first be
kept as the index of a temporal
trajectory from a list of property and
in time one to substance covering them
at time t + one recovery of a competence
through performances might be a better
term to what is usually called
Discovery but of course hydropic cotton
is too trivial an example to convince
anyone in this room of the iquity of
this phenomenon of quick transformation
and property to attributes so let me
turn instead to topos of science studies
as some of you may know Harold ginker
and his colleagues my good friend Mike
ly and others have analyzed a much more
beautiful and fundamental example when
they had the occasion to listen to the
tape of Disney and tiller's
discovery of the optical
Pulsa we wish to report this is from the
paper the discovery on January 16
196903 30 minute UT of a strong Optical
Pulses from the pulsating radio source
NP
0532 in the Crab
Nebula through an extremely rare Stroke
of Luck a tape was running at the same
time in the observatory so that the
quick transformation of a demonstrative
statement a it that is a performance to
a descriptive statement a this that is a
competence was
recorded oops
how do you do
this I have a gentleman who supposed to
help me here I
I and the gentleman comes
in doesn't arrive where I wanted okay
can we go down a little bit I don't know
this machine a little bit more a little
bit more a little bit more
sorry okay here can we click here
I'll come
back
hey
wow
can I go back
to thank you so this is one of this rare
episode when you hacked the discovery
the moment of Discovery is actually
captured by chance just at the moment
when the performances are being to
coales into competence so let's go very
quickly and I can't IM imitate the
English of those people there disne
we've got a little bit of shape now
melister will melister it's about like I
saw in that sky over there I tell you
the truth Mist there is a nice dip the
dip is actually what is going to be the
perf es that is going to be transformed
very soon into competence the dip on the
side of that Sky man I'm going to turn
this thing down machine sound we have
got a bleeding pulse here hey who you
just hear and then this beautiful
sentence by you don't suppose
that's really it do you can't be it's
right Bank in the middle of a period
look I mean right bang in the middle of
a scale this it really looks something
at the moment that's admirable it really
looks like something from here at the
moment it's growing too it's growing
it's
growing up theide a bit too growing is
also growing of a thing here the great
interest of this rare example is that
garfinger Lynch and living Stone have
studied in pain seeking detail and God
knows how pain sticking ethodology can
be the metamorphosis from the runs on
the screen in the
observatory all the way to what they
call Galilean Pulsa and Galilean is the
key term that indexes the metamorphosis
from it to this from the name of a
surprising action to what is the
substance behind or in addition to those
attributes a few minutes separates the
two stage what was dependent the
optically discovered Pula has become
fully independent in the highly specific
regime of establishing scientific
referential path that I call in the mode
of existence book ref for short this is
from gingen the Pulsar is now dep
depicted as the cause of everything that
is seen and said about it it's depicted
as existing prior to and independently
of any method for detecting it and every
way of talking about it
and
sorry I got mixed
p and three the pulsar's technically
detailed phenomena are made Anonymous
this is Garing Dragon are made Anonymous
to and Disney's presence to them as
witnessing persons and author the
admirable achievement of a paper which
is very famous in science studies but
the paper of is of course famous in
physics is that the authors don't lose
sight at any point of a temporal
trajectory to capture such a
metamorphosis as soon as the second run
is counted as similar to the first
surprising run then the active
passionate fully embedded discoverers
are already sure of not being confronted
with an artifact and they happily jump
to the conclusion that they have been
traversed by a substance which possesses
as one of its attribute the ability to
leave a trace on the screen the dip what
subsist for their work is now out there
and their naive and moving exclamation
at the very moment when they realize
that there is such a persistence in the
phenomenon proves how aware they are of
being at the intersection of two
trajectory moving in the same direction
that of a patient work in the
observatory and that of a pulsating
Optical signal now durably captured
throughout the various Institution of
astronomy observation
18 Disney this is a historic moment it's
also in the T by the way I hope it's a
historic moment we'll know when we take
another reading and that Spike there is
again right in the middle see that's
right in the middle Coke that spike is
right in the middle and that scares me
this is
beautiful we understand their excitement
they can be proud of what they have done
from now on there exist Optical pulsers
and there exist discoverers thereof a
new quality of the word has been
recovered and registered provided that
is that we the wave front in which the
discoverers as well as their Optical
pulses have become part continues to
expand in time and space for both
discoverers and Discovery time is of the
essence before we explore later what I
will call the metamorphic quality of
such an event I wish to stress that the
shift from performance to competence
could offer a common place a shared
vocabulary for Science and for the
Humanities actually this is what could
be used stylistically in order to
distinguish a paper in the Natural
Sciences from a text in literature or
critical theory when most of the actors
mobilizing their narratives are not
known in advance you have to render them
familiar to The Reader through their
most minute
Behavior it's only once you have
assembled enough of those behaviors that
it becomes possible to summarize their
action by the short hand of their name
an agency is added to the action
scientific papers solve this question of
a lack of familiarity by going down to
the most Elementary features of
perception in the case of a pulsers for
instance by showing in the text the very
graph of a pulse left by what has begun
to corales as the action of an optical
Pulsa even though you need a lot of
schooling to interpret the legend of his
slide you need only the most Elementary
cognitive skill to detect the spike a
pigeon could do it there is ver a direct
Connection in Natural Sciences between
the lack of familiarity of the Acton to
be covered and the Simplicity of a
perceptive judgment to be made by the
reader or rather I should say what we
call Natural Science is most often what
you realize you have been faced with
whenever you read papers buil on such a
big difference between the visible and
the
unknown this is where the relative
opacity of scientific literature comes
from you have constantly to fall back on
Elementary per perception to achieve
familiarity with entity that had no
common presence on the world until then
the invisible and the far away is slowly
built up from successive layers of
amazingly simple perceptive judgment
that have to be assembled one after the
other with as little Gap as possible
between every layer and of course as we
are all painfully aware the Gap is never
so small that we don't run the risk of
assembling an artifact instead of
uncovering a fact the sure thing is that
as long as the assemblage has not been
completed and the layers smoothly
stitched together you never get the
inversion from name of action to agency
the set of attributes remain like a
puzzle ready to fall off the table or a
flock of ravens ready to
disperse this built-in opacity of
scientific literature is is compound by
the array of abbreviated phenomena that
had to be previously recovered from the
new perception to be elicited those
black boxes as we call them are signaled
by technical term and most often in
those days of even more phenetic publish
and perish by acronym of value sources
so if you read for instance here the
pulsers were observed on January 16 with
your Stewart Observatory 35th inch
F reflective telescope
Etc there is nothing really obscure or
even complex in such a sentence except
for those such as myself who are
unfamiliar with what reflecting
telescope or ip21 photo multiplier or
cat consist of so the impression of
complexity come from
ignorance of course I could learn what
those element mean but then I would have
to be conducted for each of those term
from the object name back to each of his
names of action from what it is to what
it
does this is what learning means to
reverse the movement that has turned
them into
entity and in this sense black box is
never really black it just made of a
semi reflecting surface that is opaque
for the newcomer and transparent to the
specialist more exactly the ease which
which you read for the area of already
familiar black boxes or jump over them
when you are in a hurry Define you as a
specialist to whom this Vaper on Pulsa
is
dressed all of this is fairly well known
but what is not so often stressed is
that the direction is exactly similar
although reverse for for those who write
in the humanity or in the social
sciences the specific opacity of their
account excuse me the specific opacity
of their accounts come from the hard
work they have to do so as to counteract
the familiarity which their reader
believe give them access to the
characters acting in the
narrative for if I write a paper on
capitalism Wier will not slow down and
begin to be puzzled as much as we might
have done when hearing around Strong
Optical Pulses from the pting radio
Source NP
0532 in the Crab Nebula
they would accelerate and begin to endow
The Entity capitalism with a vast
numbers of attribute as if it could
deduce them from his prior
existence to slow down the rider we will
have to multiply his clear
quotes and right long yes yes often
convoluted paragraphs until we read just
the same state of puzzlement As Natural
scientists struck by the surprising
Spike made by a pan on the screen of the
instrument how far do we have to descend
layers after layer toward the elementary
features of action before reasonable and
realistic definition of capitalism can
be rebuilt from the ground up and maybe
the whole concept is an artifact that
needs to be as they say
deconstructed before being fully
displaced and
recompose and think of what would be
needed to tackle bundles of makeshift
Concepts gender
friends so when natural scientists
forgetting the opacity of their own text
mock the opacity of so many of our
writing is because they don't realize
how much easier it is for them oh yes so
very much easier with their untested
claimant to existence to obtain the
distance and the lack of familiarity
that we in other fields have to generate
by sheer obstinacy and painstaking
inquiries laboring with devices just as
artificial as theirs in our poorly
equipped Labs I mean our Studios and
libraries I remember Ro giman my mentor
at the time of writing laborator life
complaining that science is not a
selfcleaning oven and that his field
neuroendocrinology was encumbered by
many claims which were not even wrong
and that obious favorite expression and
that we had no time nor P patient to
deconstruct this was not one of his
terms of course but how can we write
clearly and directly when we find so
many Concepts so many entities so many
definition in need of
reconstruction natural scientists are
opaque because we recover new phenomena
we are opaque because they because we
have to recover the novelty of so many
old phenomena what is common is that we
all populate the the word with entity to
which is also attached or often in our
case reattached the long series of
action from which they come or to which
we lead such is it seems to me the
common space occupied by science and by
learning let's call this double movement
scholarship to cover both term No Object
name without its name of action no
competence without its performances no
pragat for what without what it does to
restate William James definition of
pragmatism it is the presence of such a
common ground between different fields
of scholarship that allows an
archaeologist specialized in the study
of clis ston stool to understand what
captivates an engineer of
nanomaterial or why an Anthropologist of
the anger of new guine will spend 10
years reconstructing their rituals of
initiation with this with the same
meticulous passion as the astronomer we
just
encountered this is what makes them part
of the same
University not because their findings
are similar not because they are
incontrovertible not because they are
Universal but because they share the
same fundamental feature when there is
an agent the list of behavior that have
composed this agency is fully
retrievable account
accountable what is admirable is that
the more formalized formalized a given
field the more obious it will be that
competence and performances will stick
together without a
gap if there is one definition of
mathematical object that is sharable
whatever philosophical position you
might lean toward is that when they are
what they what they are is entirely
describable by what they do mathematical
object are born pragmatic so to speak in
the sense that they behave just as they
are defined well not quite so that what
is meant by substance and what is meant
by attribute are exactly reversible and
very quickly the many little gaps that
have to be stitched together and slowly
smoothed out to make an object of a
mundane word such as Optical Pulsa are
not so pesky in the case of formal
entity since their behavior is entirely
dictated as they say by their def
and there are of course many gaps if
there were no Gap there would be no gain
in the demonstration but it's always
possible to jump over each of those
breaks after having retraced your path
without having to draw on any other
heterogenous
domain no one has shown that better than
ril net with the Magnificent example of
Greek geometry when he follows how this
miracle there is no other word was made
possible by the discovery of Highly
specific scrypto visual
procedure I quote I suggest therefore
that one part of the answer to why are
Greek mathematical proof we are is that
proofs are compartmentalized from
broader discussion so that their
structure is wholly
autonomous one doing mathematics one
does nothing else instead of a
multi-dimensional structure of interest
and implication of natural discourse
Greek mathematics abstract mathematical
relationship and that's the most
important sentence this is perhaps
obvious for science but this is I've
probably read to be read tongue and Chic
but the Greek mathematics had no earlier
science to imitate in this
respect when doing mathematics one does
nothing else and as you know if you have
read a book unfortunately that's exactly
what Plato did not limit himself to
doing
and the invention according to Nets of a
formalist definition of formalism that
has generated so much confusion and
philosophy and politic that would be
another question formalism offers a
formidable
Advantage yes but it does not make it
that much different from what is done in
all other field of
scholarship it is just that formalism is
simultaneously easier no competence
without performance and more combersome
you have to stick to the path of
demonstration step after step without
jumping at out any moment to use any
other source of information any
multi-dimensional like all of us do who
are not formalist this make for huge
difference in
skill but not for incompatibility
between domains in that sense formalism
is scholarship to and such a common
ground seems to me more realistic than
the usual division between nomothetic
and ideographic discipline or the more
refined distinction offered by my friend
Yan hacking about various styles of
reasoning is there really such an
opposition between the science of nature
as those of
interpretation I have followed scientist
around for nearly 40 years now and I've
never seen one but did not have to
interpret the many disjointed traces
that had been assembled to turn a set of
performances into a
competence no scholar deduces an
automaton but scientists are all
brothers and sisters of exegesis the
mother of all interpretive
skills the grandmother being this
reading of delicate traces that Tim
inold the Anthropologist as slow
cleverly taught us to
follow scholarship and interpretation
are what a university should be made of
nothing to surprise Mr Tanner if I
understand who was a Biblical exit
himself what makes scholars believe that
they are in different camps is that
their respective writing are opaque to
one another and it's true that all those
different form of opacity may be
exaggerated technical jargon risk
proliferating either by needlessly
multiplying the acronym and the Greco
Latin gibberish or by multiplying p
and playing with word and etymologies
and nonse or by imposing a useless
formalism when no one is needed but even
this should not be
derided because our common opponent
those remember wish to get rid of
whatever slows them down have only one
model in in mind they already know what
the word is made off who needs new
agencies and how register the behavior
cliche will do the job fairly well by
unpr problematically and immediately
transporting their meaning to the other
side of the
planet powered by this source of energy
that I call double click they think at
lighting
speed no need for square Quotes no need
for new instrument no need for
literature no need for humanities no
need for critical
exes please don't split
hairs I'm afraid to say but we are all
those who work in Laboratories as as
well as those who work in libraries hair
Splitters splitting what is often as
thin as a hair is the only way to make
sure that behind the concept and entity
the substance there Remains The Long
series of properties that allow them to
subsist and not the other way around
never meet an actor without its Network
you may blackbox them but a black box is
not a cliche the content of an a black
box is fully accountable to use Garing
girl's term which in addition of being a
philosophy of inquiry is also an ethic
of research so it seemed that our modor
against the threat to the two culture
should be hair Splitters of all
disciplines
unite before resuming me my effort at
splitting even more hair I want to offer
you opportunity of a little crib to make
sure that you are still with
me I will use this old example proposed
by franois basti a physiologist turn
stian of a gri masian school whose work
on the inner mechanism of scientific
paper has been very important to me the
test is fairly simple can you detect
what is common in those two paragraphs
first I read the procession slowly
progressed through the winding streets
of the Old City from ey up in the
belfrey I was easily able to distinguish
the little Scouts the musician and the
sons of France and the men from the
church Council carrying the canopy the
crowd was lined along each pavement and
although most were only Thunder Bel s
they listen quietly as the daughters of
Mary pass
praying however I noticed that at every
street corner the scouts who were
impatient to get a bite to eat at the
chaplain's headquarter threed their way
with difficulty through the
loers they pass from one street to the
next shortcutting the procession and
then they dispers toward the
funfare moving from the main street to
the alleys the procession lost its
children
and little by little was whittled down
to core of pous but middleaged
Souls paragraph
two the result detail can be perfectly
explained if one accept the hypothesis
that the walls of the vascular and
urinary hairpins are much more permeable
to water than to sodium this would
generate a countercurrent water exchange
between the ascending and descending
limbs if the walls of a duct are more
permeable to water transversal diffusion
should cause a fraction of marked water
molecues circulating in the descending
limbs to pass into the ascending ones by
exchanges at each
level well I'm sure you had no
difficulty pass this little
examp right two different narratives one
single tree of
actors whereas the first story the one
on the left what is slowly being
concentrated through the mandering
street of my native city of bone in
burgundy of the POU of the daughters of
Mary in the second what is being slowly
concentrated for the countercurrent of
hamster kind herin is the
sodium in the first paragraph what Lees
away at every corner are the little
Scout while in the second it
radioactivity tagged water for the
apparent distinction between some
episodes of a writer's early life and a
serious scientific paper runs a common
set of
forces this is where the distinction of
actant and actor becomes
visible superficially there is no
resemblance between a city and a kidney
but if you consider the more Mo abstract
movement of progressive concentration
through an ascending and descending
mechanism of some sort they can receive
alternative
figuration and it's not even the case
that the second could be taken as a more
exoteric than the first the second being
the right one because if it's true that
transversal diffusion might be a term
known only by physiologist and also by
plumbers we know a lot about e exens I'm
sure that none of you has any idea of
what fys def France could mean
as to the daughter of Mary this is I'm
afraid a pretty local and by now totally
vanished religious Association of my
pous
youth there is of course a crucial
difference between the two narrative
well underlined by
basti the author delegated observer in
the belfrey is undou with the capacity
of highballing the whole phenomenon as
one continuous
stretch while the the physiology olist
in the second case has to reconstruct
the time the flow of sodium in the
kidney by keeping the traces of many
hamsters killed in succession and
reconstructing the virtual Destiny of
one sodum procession if I can say by a
set of freeze frames taken at different
interval so the advantage of a writer in
the first story is that we have no
difficulty Imagining the movement of a
procession
we rely on similar example even if you
don't know unfortunate of you the city
of bone while the writer of the second
has to make the reader imagine the
smooth process out of a succession of
split images that have to be shown in a
table and here again we notice just as
much as in the optical pulser case that
whenever the phenomenon is invisible the
only way to register is to fall back on
even simpler perceptive judgment
judement and a set of simple convention
readings frame from left to right just
as in a comic strip connecting the dots
and comparing the different areas but in
both cases process or procession a
movement has to Be
Imagined without fiction fi in the
language of inquiry no science would be
possible this little example might seem
too trivial
but I ask you to take it as a mere
signal post that designate below the
Apparently vast distinction between
let's say science and literature
objective statement and narrative
something else but I call for want of
accepted term the metamorphic
zone out of which all agencies
emerge in my jargon the prefix meta
simply means that in addition to the
anthropomorphic character the Scout and
the daughters of Mary and the
phoric characters the countercurrent the
sodium the radioactively tagged water
there is something
else that Define their role and
distribute their movement or something
that has to be at work before this
Division and on which the shape and the
work morphic of things narrated always
depend in the following lecture I will
try to render this concept more
precise metamorphic also designate the
place the locus of those we should call
shape
Changers those who are able to shift
roles and figures around and to give
form to the phenomena they address or
rather by whom they are
traversed unfortunately we have only the
audio tape of the discovery of the
optical Pulsa but it would have been
even more telling to have a video record
of their
gestures look at scientist speaking look
at their GES when scientists explain
what they do and it's the same whether
talk of mathematical object natural
science social science or Humanity their
gestures designate exactly this Locus
where totally different register extend
their
properties as Patrick blackhead the
great physicist said the experimental
physicist is the jack of all trades a
versatile but amateur Craftsman he must
blow glass and turn metal Carpenter
photograph wi electric circuit and will
be a master of Gadget of all kind he may
find invaluable training as an engineer
and can profit Always by utilizing his
gift as a mathematician in such activity
will he be engaged for three quarters of
his working day and that's a beautiful
sentence during the rest he must be a
physicist
that is he must cultivate an intimacy
with the physical world cultivate an
intimacy with the physical
word scientists that work take upon
themselves literally upon their own
flesh the force that Travers them and
for which there would be no name without
their making them act they become black
holes ancient ire exotic ritual profound
concept or rather they gave those entity
the agencies they would not have had
without their creation this place of
exchange this is why I never thought
that objectivity and subjectivity could
make sense of scientific discovery and
amazingly this place of exchange is even
more visible when the scientists cannot
make any gesture not even
speak as elen M has demonstrated in a
beautiful study of a physicist Steven
Hawking imprison in his wheelchair in
this case even to gesture toward the
black hole is Possible only through the
activation of a vast organization of
instrument speech
synthetizer nurses doctors helpers
translator thus merging together in one
single entity the body of the active
scientist and prison and the merging
together with the institution of science
hence the title of the book Hawkings
Incorporated the most immaterial and the
most material are fused together
the largest Cosmic order and the
smallest office in Cambridge are
connected this is a beautiful example of
the wavefront we have already
encountered the problem is that it's
very difficult to concentrate attention
on such a metamorphic Zone without
losing sight of
it and in addition I'm very conscious
that the word narrative and even worse
the word
storytelling would not pass muster with
natural scientist even if they accept
terms like
interpretation exeresis and scholarship
but I have proposed as a common umbrella
for all the discipline assembl in a
university a university of hair spitters
of course as soon as an entity has been
transformed into a substance namely as
soon as it has shifted and revers from a
name of action in into main of object
from it to this from a performance to a
competence immediately the substance
goes away in time and in space and now
is impossible to reconnect to its
Discoverer except to get Nobel prizes of
course this is what ginger has coded
with the word
Galilean probably from H but platonic
should have pointed to the same
transformation that's a delicate passage
and I'm sorry to bother you with
but you have to be patient reductionism
can mean at least two completely
different things one is the reduction of
a substance to its attribute that's a
positive one the other is the
substitution of a substance for the
attributes the two meaning go in
entirely different
direction reductionism in the first
meaning is a common property of all
discipline of
scholarship whenever we have an agency
we need to be able to retrieve the set
of action out of which it has emerged as
an
agent this is what is meant by the
expression of being
accountable and once again it's also
what James has defined as the main
tenant of
pragmatism this is true for odd concept
such as difference in der's dragon as
well as for the many pathway for which a
gene is able to act off of the
definition of a higs bosom you have to
show what it does if you wish to say
what it is we call Scholars or
scientists those who are able to
describe for the attribute the agency
with which they populate the word and
it's always through some sort of
Trials the problem is that reductionism
now in the second meaning is just the
opposite as soon as you have the
agency you may feel you are now allowed
to dispense entirely with licking it to
the list of action of which it's no
longer the summary but now the source in
the first sense reductionism is the
glory of all Sciences in the second is
the bane of science what has generated
what is often called the scientific
worldview and what has discouraged so
many young people from engaging in
research one meaning make you so to
speak friends of inter pable object a
beautiful sentence from Miguel Tam the
others make you someone who thinks that
the task of describing may be dispensed
with in one version you are fully
accountable in the other you are no
longer
accountable in a famous sentence from
the concept of nature white demanded
that we differentiate the two meaning of
reductionism when he said for natural
philosophy everything perceived is in
nature we may not pick and
choose for us the red glow of a sunset
should be as much part of nature as are
the molecules and electric waves by
which men of science would explain the
phenomenon it is for natural philosophy
to analyze how these various element of
nature are
connected if we may not pick and choose
it's because the registration of one
phenomenon cannot erase from the world
the registration of any other one once
red has been retro engineered into
electric waves the glow of a sunset is
still there with all its other
properties begging for a
description a word of glowing Sunset
without electric waves would be indeed a
tragically impoverished world but so
would be one where electric wave would
have eliminated the glory of
sunsets eliminativism is the
philosophical equivalent of what is
called in geopolitic ethnic
cleansing this is where the two meaning
of reductionism crash into one
another to end this first lecture let me
give you an example exactly similar to
the conflict between red and sunset but
where the situation is not imagined by
some armchair philosopher but built as
what I call a diplomatic
encounter in our inquiries on mode of
existence that I've launched we multiply
those kind of situation where the claim
of one description is no longer able to
eliminate from existence the claim of
another description not because of Any
inder to truth what is called relativism
but for exact opposite
reason namely to register more reality
thanks to the use of a larger numbers of
templates pluralism is here understood
not as a plurality of point of view on
the same
reality but as a multiplicity of type of
agency to register more reality hence
the word mood of
existence
I'm sure you had the experience that
when people use as their template the
so-called Mind Body it becomes very hard
not to pick and choose inevitably their
hands begin to dance from left to right
involuntary as if in a sort of
TR actually a Coura either it's in the
mind or it's in the body or in some sort
of psychosomatic mix of a two so this is
why in February this year I arrange I
arrange a situation where I try to make
just as impossible to describe a
phenomenon by using the Mind Body pincer
as for the fox and the stalk of the fa
to each out of each other
dish the case participant had chosen was
that of Huntington
Korea a degenerative condition caused by
one single dominant gene for which there
is a test by had no cure Huntington
Korea is ver an ideal candidate for
playing the role of a
body I mean the causal body is so much
loved by reductionist of a second
category one gene one condition sure
death we had complicated the matter by
having among the participant two
representative of a very original
patient organization called Ding Dang
dong to play with uning
Emily herma and Valerie
Pier normally what is expect from
patient is that they occupy the position
of those who suffer in their flesh while
flesh or body is already Prim and that
they State the lived experience they
have of a disease or that they complain
about the lack of funding for research
of the bad ways in which Social Security
reimburse them for their
expenses but those two inspired by AIDS
activist claim to generate knowledge
about the Huntington disease and not
just a subjective interpretation of what
it is to live for the disease Emily and
Valerie had created no less than a
research
institute now we complicated the
situation even further by inviting a
scientist this is the meeting of great
reputation Alan Tobin who himself had an
important role in the discovery of a
gene and in following the pathway for
which the disease is being activated
into the
brain as is always the case when you
come closer to research scientists in
practice are not
eliminativist sure enough Alan began to
let the genetic makeup and then the
brain connection caused by this Gene to
proliferate in all sorts of unexpected
Direction there is one gene but it's
very difficult to know when the onset of
a disease would appear the action of a
gene even in this case is not a
straightforward Affair it opens many
Avenues soon the activist of DDD and the
Brain scientist began to talk to one
another and apply the maxim by whad in
natural philosophy we cannot pick and
choose gone was the Mind Body
pincer especially because I had somewhat
disingenuously complicated the situation
still further by adding to the feast
another aable companion the ethnos
psychiatrist Toby naton a disciple of
George D and maybe some of you have seen
the film Jimmy P Psychotherapy of a
brain Indian by Arno de which is a
resurrection of
deu D is the inventor of it no
Psychiatry so when the first guest had
entered into the discussion of inv
involuntary movement which is a
characteristic of a disease what is
called a Korea and what has given its
name to the Huntington disease when they
had began to realize that the scientific
notion of involuntary movement was up to
question Toby as if he had been beaten
by a
spider suddenly recounted the story of a
Tarantella this dance ritual and
therapeutic music of southern Italy
music actually ritual it turned out that
Valerie had participa into a dance class
open to Huntington patient and where
step by step what was supposed to be a
pathological dance and what was supposed
to be a recreational or artistic dance
had begun to
merge what it is to have such a disease
that is to be traversed by those
movement was open to
redescription to the gene was added now
now many other agencies that make the
patient move it become impossible to
pick and choose we found ourselves in a
completely different situation than what
would have been expected from using mind
body as our
template and of course here was also a
very different moral
situation since it would have been
inconceivable now to tell someone what
just learn that they carry the gene that
causes unting on Korea and remember very
a test but there is no cure and many
actually potential patient don't take
the test to say well sorry this is a
degenerative condition end up ending up
in dementia and sure death that's your
fate degenerative might not be in the
end the exact word to describe
Huntington so there is a poison in mind
body that this experiment I tried to
extract from the description
yet the description of the disease and
at this point of course natural
philosophy meets
politics at the end of this lecture on
agency we have two definition of what it
is to do with search and they are
complementary one is to be friends of
interpretable object the other one is to
be hair Splitters not to pick and
choose the next task is to abide by
whitee head's
injunction it is for natural philosophy
to analyze how these various element of
nature are
connected in the end the old and
venerable term natural philosophy might
be might be the best umbrella for
University and it's a great irony that
the massive movement to discipline
disrupt and weaken basic science as well
as humanity is being made in the name
name of
accountability because if you have
followed me being accountable mean
exactly the opposite of what evaluators
administrators and finance says it is
it's not to prove how useful research is
how quickly turns into a profit how
efficient it is for designing a
product but how securely yes securely we
are all able to attach the definition of
an agent active in the world to the set
of property that Define such an
agent so I should modify the motto I
offered
earlier against those who pick and
choose hair Splitters of all trades and
countries unite thank you very
[Applause]
[Music]
much